حيّاكم الله في بودكاست السوق من ثمانية
في حلقتنا اليوم بنتكلم عن خبر مهم جدًا
نظارة «فيجن برو» من أبل
واللي عبدالله كان ينتظر الحديث عنها منذ الحلقة الماضية
طبعًا نقاش مطوّل عن النظارة
وأهم التقنيات اللي فيها
وسؤال نحاول نجيب عنه
واللي هو هل هذا هو مستقبل التقنية؟
هل بنلبس نظارات في المستقبل مثل ما نستخدم كلنا اليوم آيفونات وجوالات ذكية؟
بعدها راح ننتقل للحديث عن مناوشات
بين «كريم» و«طلبات» و«ديليفرو» في الإمارات بسبب عرض قدمته شركة «كريم»
وبعدها راح ننتقل للحديث عن جولة استثنائية
بقيمة 105 مليون دولار لشركة تركية متخصصة في الذكاء الاصطناعي اسمها «إنسايدر»
وتفسير لأهم التقنيات اللي عند الشركة
بالإضافة طبعًا لأهمية الجولة واستثمار الجهاز القطري الاستثماري فيها
وبعدين راح نتكلم عن تدوينة مهمة
كتبها مارك أندريسن مؤسس صندوق أندريسن هورويتز
عن الذكاء الاصطناعي، وكيف أنه هو متحمس جدًا للذكاء الاصطناعي
ويخاصم كل أحد يحذِّر من الذكاء الاصطناعي ويخوُّف الناس منه
وأخيرًا راح نتكلم عن انقسام صناديق سكويا حول العالم
سكويا أهم مستثمر
وقد يكون أقدم مستثمر جريء في العالم
أعلن عن انقسام صناديقه
الصيني والهندي والأمريكي عن بعضها
أيش معنى هذا الانقسام؟ أيش تفسيره؟
أيش خفايا هذا القرار؟
قبل ما تبدأ الحلقة أتمنى أنكم تشاركونها
مع أي شخص تعتقدون أنه مهتم بهذا النوع من المحتوى
أما الآن فاستمتعوا
معاذ يبدو لي أنك سعيد
النصف الثاني من الأسبوع اللي راح
أبل في مؤتمرهم أعلنوا عن منتج جديد نوعيًا
كان ودي أتكلم عنه، بس أستحي أنا اللي أطرحه للمشاهدين وأنت موجود
بحكم علاقتك طبعًا الوثيقة بالرئيس التنفيذي
عبدالله أنت تستهبل علي
بس ترى أنت اللي في نهاية الحلقة الماضية
أوصيت بمشاهدة إعلان أبل عن النظارة الجديدة
واللي كان هو مجرَّد إشاعة أو شيء متوقع
ويبدو أنه علاقتك الوطيدة بالرئيس التنفيذي
هي اللي وصَّلت لك المعلومة
اللي ما كان أحد يدري عنها، لكن أنت قلتها بكل إصرار أنه كأنها بتصير خلاص
ومتأكد ما شاء الله عليك وثقة
لكن لا النظارة طبعًا موضوع أتوقع بنطوِّل فيه
ماهو بشيء كذا بسيط
يمكن فيه عدة مفاجآت
لازم نتكلم عنها بخصوص النظارة
أول شيء وجود معالجين خاصين فيها
معالج الإم تو
ومعالج جديد الذي هو الآر ون
مما يعطيها إمكانيات حوسبية خاصة فيها
وهذه كانت يمكن المفاجأة الكبرى أنها تعتبر جهاز
حوسبي كامل متكامل
يعني مثلها مثل الآيباد والأيفون أو حتى الماك
بنموذج مستقل أصلًا
وهذه المفاجأة الثانية
بالضبط، أنه نظام تشغيلي كامل متكامل
اسمه (Vision OS)، على غِرار (iOS) و (iPadOS) وغيرها
يعني العديد من المفاجآت
طبعًا يمكن فيه مفاجآت سلبية سالفة البطارية
واللي أصلًا طالعة على جنب لوحدها
وأيضًا مدة شحنها ساعتين
أنا بالنسبة لي من أكبر المفاجآت السلبية
ويمكن أنت تستغرب من كلامي، لكن كون إنها نظارة
هي مفاجأة سلبية بالنسبة لي
أنا أدري أنه كل أحد كان يتكلم عن وجود نظارة
لكن ماتوقعت أنه أبل تسوي نظارة!
ليش؟
لأني صراحةً لست من المؤمنين اللي يتخيلون أنه المستقبل في نظارات
أتخيل أشكال مختلفة لأجهزة حسوبية مختلفة
لكن ما تخيل أنها نظارة
تغطي عيونك بالكامل
طبعًا غير أنه فيه عنصرية واضحة تجاه الناس
اللي يلبسون النظارة زيي أنا وإياك
الزحمة اللي بتصير على وجهك
أو أنك تضطر إنك تسوي عملية عشان تستخدم تقنيات المستقبل
لكن نريد حل جذري أكبر معاذ
بس أيش هو عدسة؟
بدري شوي على العدسات
ما أدري أيش الحل ولّا كان ما تلقاني هنا
كان ممكن تلقاني في كوبرتينو
لكن
لكن فعلًا والله
يمكن السؤال الجوهري حول المنتج
بلا شك أنه المنتج فيه مزايا خرافية، ومُبهر على أصعدة كبيرة وكثيرة
لكن يبقى السؤال الرئيسي الجوهري عندي
هل مستقبل الحوسبة ومستقبل الأجهزة اللوحية
ومستقبل الجوالات هو نظارة؟
وما أدري أيش الجواب
كان عندنا تجربة قوقل
تجربة فاشلة بحتة
لعدة أسباب من أهمها أنه الجهاز كان يعتبر مثير للشفقة للشخص اللي يلبسه
حتى صار محل الطقطقة لأي شخص لابس الجهاز
خصوصًا وأنه كان فيه كاميرا واضحة فيه
فكان يعتبر نوع من التجسس الاجتماعي
أيش اللي أنت ماشي ولابس كاميرا على وجهك وتصورنا ونحن ما ندري!
فيه نوع من الاختراق للخصوصية والعشوائية، عرفت؟
بس معاذ كانت شوي أبكر من وقتها النظارة
لأنه بعدين جات سناب شات
هذه يقولونها محبين قوقل
لا بس اسمع، بعدين سناب شات صارت فكرة حلوة أنه نظارتك فيها كاميرا
والآن هذه «أبل فيجن برو»
فيها كاميرات مو كاميرا وحدة خارجية
عشان تشوف حركات يدك، وعشان تشوف العالم حولك وغيرها
أعتقد جزء منها
ما أعتقد نظارة قوقل كان منتج ناجح
لكن أعتقد جزء منها كان
بدري شوي
وهذا أحد الناس اللي جرّبوا النظارة
وقضى معها نصف ساعة
وهم أعتقد عدد محدود من المُدوِّنين المعروفين
أحدهم هو مارك إس، المُدوِّن المعروف حق يوتيوب
وقال أنه كله كوم ولما شفت كيف أنه الأب جالس مع عياله
ويصورهم بالنظارة
كان هذا بالنسبة لي منظر مختلف تمامًا عن كل التقنيات اللي قدمتها الشركة
كان هذا منظر مثير للتساؤل
أو مثير حتى للاشمئزاز
أنه هل هذا هو المستقبل؟
يقول أنه هدف اللحظة هذه أني أنا بوثقّها، وبوثقّها بتقنية ثلاثية الأبعاد
على أساس إني بعدين أقدر اشوفها أنا وعيالي صح؟
طيب يقول أيش تجربة الآخرين اللي جالسين في الغرفة؟
فيه واحد لابس نظارة ووجهتها سوداء
ويصورنا وكلنا عارفين أنه يصورنا
بطريقة مثيرة للاشمئزاز فعلًا
فعشان كذا هل هذا هو المستقبل؟
جزء منها يعرفونها، لما يقولون «فيس تايم»
لما تسخدم «فيس تايم» بالنظارة هذه
يبدو أنه الفكرة يستخدمون الذكاء الصناعي
أنه يورّي وجهك للي قدامك
ووجهه اللي أمامك بمحاكاة
وليس الوجه صورة فعلية
لأنه صورتك الفعلية لابس فيجن برو
بس أنا ودّي أتكلم عن شغلتين: شغلة البطارية إنها برَّا
أعتقد في الحقيقة أنها كانت قرار ذكي
مو تحدي
لأنه يخففون وزن فيجن برو نفسه
صحيح، وهذا فرق رئيسي بينه وبين «الكويست» حق مِتا
حاطين البطارية ورا، ووزنها أثقل فعلًا
والنقطة الثانية معاذ أعتقد
خاصة الكاميرات الخارجية أو التوجُّه العام لـ فيجن برو
أنه يبغى يقرأ حركات يدك بدون جهاز، بدون حتى الخاتم على يدك، بدون أي شيء
أعتقد هذه نقطة تقنية خرافية الصراحة مو هينة
وهذا التفوق الرئيسي أيضًا على النظارات الأخرى كلها
لأنه كلها فيها أجهزة تحكُّم
بس عبدالله شوف أنت ذكرت نقطة فيس تايم
هي النظارة بغض النظر هي المستقبل أو لا
الأهم أعتقد هو التقنيات اللي طورتها الشركة واللي أعلنت عنها
أنت ذكرت إحداها
فيه عدة استخدامات للذكاء الاصطناعي من بينها اللي أنت ذكرتها
اللي هي قدرة الشركة على مسح وجه المستخدم
عند الاستخدام للمرة الأولى، وبعدين لما يكون فيه مكالمة فيس تايم
يصير فيه نموذج ثلاثي الأبعاد لوجهك بشكل حقيقي
بمعنى إذا أنت غمزت في الحقيقة وأنت لابس النظارة
وجهك الثلاثي الأبعاد النموذج حقه اللي هم سووه لك
يروح يغمز ويظهر في مكالمة فيس تايم مع أحد ثاني
فهذه محاكاة طبعًا موجودة في مثل نظارة كويست مِتا
لكنها موجودة على شكل صورة رمزية
شكل كرتوني، مو على شكلك الحقيقي
هذه محاكاة حقيقية لشكلك
فهذا كان أحد أهم استخدامات الذكاء الاصطناعي
لأنه تستخدمها بشكل حقيقي أو في الوقت الحقيقي
معاذ جميل تشوف تطوّر هذه التقنية
للوجه الحقيقي أو نموذج الوجه الحقيقي مو بس الصور الرمزية
لأن يمكن قد جربت فيس تايم يمديك تختار وجه أو شخصية معينة
وتسوي الحركة بعينك، والكاميرا تترجمها إلى حركة في الصورة الرمزية نفسها
على الأقل مع ولد وبنت أخوي هذا جزء كبير من فيس تايم اللي يطلبونه مني
فتشوفها، الآن جميل تشوفها بمحاكاة لوجهك الحقيقي
النقطة الثانية عبدالله أنه الكاميرات اللي موجودة عند بؤبؤ الأعين
الظاهر فيه كاميرتين لكل عين، فعندنا أربع كاميرات
هذه الكاميرات قاعدة تقرأ حركة الأعين
وفي البداية زي بصمة الوجه
تسوّي لها أول مرة ضبط بحيث إنها تتعوَّد على عيونك وعلى حركتها
وبعدها تقدر هذه الكاميرات إنها تتنبأ
برغبتك الحقيقية بناءً على حركة عيونك
وهذا يعني إذا أخذنا
شركة «نورن لينك» والتقنية اللي قاعدة تحاول تسويها
واللي هي قراءة النبضات العصبية في دماغك
على أساس أنها تعرف تتنبأ بالأشياء اللي تبغى تسويها
هذا على المستوى الأول، مستوى النبضات العصبية
الآن نحن نتكلم عن المستوى الثاني
من النبضة العصبية إلى العين، ومن العين إلى الجهاز
فأنا أعتقد هذا إنجاز يعني فضيع جدًا
وفعلًا اللي جرَّب النظارة
مارك إس كان يتكلم ويقول هذا أكثر شيء أبهرني
لم أُجرب أي شيء بهذا المستوى في حياتي
أنه كيف أنا بس ألِّف عيني لفة بسيطة
يعرف إني أنا بدل ما أناظر هذه الأيقونة
يروح للأيقونة اللي جنبها
وهنا نجي للتقنية الثالثة
واللي هي اللي قلت عنها استخدام الأيادي
كيف أني أنا لما ألِّف من أيقونة لأيقونة، بعدين أسوِّي حركة معينة بيدي
تقدر الكاميرات الجانبية اللي موجودة أسفل النظارة أنها تشوف حركة اليد وتترجمها
إلى أمر برمجي يتحوّل إلى نتيجة في داخل المنتج
صراحةً هذه التقنيات هي اللي فعليًا تحمِّس
واللي ممكن يكون لها تطبيقات خرافية في المستقبل
وفي أجهزة أبل المختلفة
بغض النظر عن النظارة
هل النظارة هي المستقبل أو لا؟
فية  نقطة أو ممكن مو ميزة ثالثة مباشرة
بس قرار تقني كذلك كان مهم أنا شفته
اللي هو أنه النظارة فعليًا مو واقع افتراضي واقع مختلط
اللي هو إذا كنت تتفرج على شيء
ولّا تتعامل مع برنامج معين وقرَّب منك أحد
يقلبها إلى تقريبًا واقع معزز
اللي هو تشوف الشخص برَّا
والكاميرات الداخلية تصور له زي عيونك، باقي وجهك
فالخلط بين النوعين من الواقع المعزز والواقع الافتراضي
ترى كان توجّه كبير
إيمان الشركة
عبدالله هذه النقطة الأخيرة اللي ذكرتها مرة مهم التوضيح فيها
لأنه حتى ذكرها مارك إس
كان يقول أنه كثير من اللقطات في الإعلان حق أبل
كان يظهر فيها شخص يلبس النظارة وطالعة عيونه
فيقول هل فعلًا النظارة
إنك تقدر تشوف من خلالها ولّا لا؟
هذا كان سؤال طرحوه الكثير من الناس
والجواب أنه لا
النظارة فيها شاشة من برَّا
والشاشة هذه مو تستخدم كاميرات تشوف عيونك، لا
وإنما تستخدم نفس الصورة الرمزية اللي تظهر في فيس تايم
عشان تكمّل وجهك
بناءً على حركاته من خلال الكاميرات اللي قاعدة تتابع عيونك
لو غمزت أو لو ضحكت أو شيء بتتغيَّر شكلك على الشاشة اللي برا
لكن هو ليس تصوير حقيقي لصورتك، وإنما هو استخدام لتقنية الذكاء الاصطناعي
بحيث أني أنا أحاكي وجهك على الشاشة اللي برّا
فهذا أيضًا كان شيء صراحة
كمية الجهد المبذول
بالطريق سوّوا شاشة مائلة شوي قدام
بالطريق يعني
هي مو المشكلة الرئيسية
لا اسمع، منتج تقنيًا مبهر
خليني أتكلم على بعض التساؤلات الآن
التساؤل الأول
شفت استخدامات كثيرة في التجربة، أو في الفيديوهات اللي طلعت
تتعلق بجانب العمل مو جانب الاستخدام الشخصي
أو حتى ربطهم مع برامج مايكروسوفت
يبدو أنه كان فيه جزء من الإعلان عليه من البداية
فيبدو أنه فيه تركيز على جانب الأعمال
مو بس على جانب الأفراد
النقطة الثانية هي
اللي طبعًا أنت ما بتذكرها
بس لازم عشان الأمانة
سعرها 3500 دولار
يعتبر غالي جدًا لكثير من الناس
خاصة أنه «كويست ثري» يمكن نتكلم عنه بعد شوي من مِتا
مخطط أنه يكون بـ 500 دولار
النقطة الثالثة
ولكن كويست برو بـ 1500 للتوضيح
بس نتكلم عن ثري لأنه فيه مقابلة لمارك زوكربيرغ قريب
النقطة الثالثة وأعتقد كذلك مهمة
شوي كأننا عدنا للوراء من ناحية التوزيع
المنتج أُعلن عنه الآن في مؤتمر المطورين عشان المطورين يأخذون وقتهم في بناء التطبيقات
وترتيب تطبيقاتهم إنها تشتغل
بيتوفر في أمريكا بداية السنة القادمة المخطط
وباقي العالم بعدين
فرجعنا لنقطة التوزيع بأولوية مختلفة لدول كثيرة
فما أدري كيف شفت الثلاث النقاط؟
صراحة خاصة نقطة التركيز على الأعمال
أنا أشوفها خاصة مع نقطة السعر
3500 دولار ممكن يكون فيها ارتباط
أنه يرونها جانب كبير منها أعمال تجارية بين الشركات
هنا يصير السؤال
هل هذه النظارة بتكون بديل للآيفون؟ أنا ما أتوقع أبدًا
خصوصًا مع عمر البطارية
وخصوصًا مع أنك ما تقدر تستخدمها في القطار ولّا في السيارة زي الآيفون
لكن قد تكون بديل للآيباد
قد تكون إلى حدٍ ما
أو قد تكون الأهم من ذلك بديل للكمبيوتر
وهنا كان فيه مزايا حلوة
ومن أهمها أنها تقدر تصير
إنها تقدر ترتبط عن طريق أعتقد
الإير بلاي بجهاز الماك
وبالتالي تقدر كل الشرائح اللي ظاهرة عندك أو النوافذ اللي ظاهرة عندك في جهازك الماك
فجأة تصير عندك في النظارة
وتقدر تبدأ تتحكم فيها
وتنعكس التغييرات اللي سويتها على جهازك الماك
غير أنها بحد ذاتها بكون فيها تطبيقات
أكيد هي بتبدأ بتطبيقات أبل وتتوجه لتطبيقات أخرى
من أهم التطبيقات اللي بتكون موجودة
التطبيقات الرئيسية حق العمل
فبالتالي فيه احتمالية
وهذا يعتمد على طبيعة الاستخدام
أنها تكون بديل فعلًا للكمبيوتر
خصوصًا الآن مع فكرة الناقل الصوتي اللي تطوَّر كثير بالسنوات الأخيرة
صرت اليوم أنت تقدر تكتب إيميلات عن طريق صوتك ما تحتاج لوحة مفتايح
مع أنه أيضًا تقدر تستخدم لوحة مفاتيح معاها
وكان هذا شيء لطيف جدًا
هذا من زاوية، من ناحية موضوع التطبيقات
بالعكس أنا أشوفها حركة ذكية لأنه هم ما كانوا يبغون يعلنون
للشركات أو للمطورين لوحدهم
من غير ما يورونها للعالم
لأنه بلا شك مافي مطوِّر بيتركها
أو بخلي الخبر عنده
وهذا التحدي اللي دائمًا مع أبل
أبل تحب السرية
فبالتالي اضطروا أنه يكون الإعلان للكل
فصار هذا النوع من الحماس عند المستهلك
بس قالوا له اسمع ترى لازم تستنى شوي
من ناحية توزيعه على الدول
أنا أعتقد هذا بس إعلان مبدئي
دائمًا أبل سريعة جدًا
في عملية طرح المنتجات لكل دول العالم
ما أعتقد أنه بكون فيه بطء حقيقي
في شحن المنتج لدول مختلفة
والسعر؟
السعر ما أشوف أنه مشكلة كبيرة
أول شيء هذه النسخة الأولى
وصراحةً أنا قعدت أرجع شوي وأشوف
أسعار العديد من المنتجات حق أبل وكيف وضعها
على سبيل المثال، عندك مثلًا الآيفون يعتبر هو أغلى جهاز جوال
إلى اليوم الآيفون يمثل سبعة وعشرون بالمئة
من أنظمة تشغيل الجوالات
بتقول مو كثير، صح مو كثير
لكن الآيفون كوسم تجاري
هو يمثل اثنان وعشرون بالمئة من مبيعات كل الجوالات
وهو رقم واحد كوسم، عرفت؟
بتقول لي أجهزة الأندرويد مجتمعة
طبعًا تبيع أكثر من الآيفون كعدد
بس كوسم لوحده بالضبط
نفس الشيء عندك ساعة أبل
ساعة أبل واللي تعتبر غالية جدًا
مقارنة بالساعات الثانية غالية جدًا جدًا
ساعة أبل حققت ستون بالمئة من إيرادات كل الساعات الذكية في عام 2022
وباعت حول اثنان وثلاثون بالمئة من عدد الساعات في نفس العام
ومع أنها أغلى بكثير
وأيضًا الإيربودز تعتبر من المنتجات الغالية جدًا
وفيه لها كثير منافسين قبلها وبعدها
يحاولون يسوون نفس المنتج
وبمزايا أكثر وبسعر أرخص
إريربودز باعت العام الماضي 82 مليون نسخة
واقتربت من 500 مليون نسخة
نصف مليار نسخة باعتها من عام 2016
فأنا أشوف أنه أبل قدرت أنها
تجاوب على هذا السؤال من قبل
السعر ليس الهم الرئيسي عند المستخدم
أنا أبيع تجربة استثنائية
وأبيع تجربة في داخل عالم أبل
اللي ما أحد أصلًا يقدر ينافسني فيه
فبالتالي اللي حريص على تجربة استثنائية
واللي حريص على منتج ذو جودة عالية جدًا
راح يضحي شوي من أجل السعر
لكن بلا شك
لا ننسى أنه هذا المنتج اسمه «برو»
فدائمًا منتجات «أبل برو» هي تكون الأغلى
هل فيه نسخة أقل شوي؟
يمكن أقل كاميرات أو أقل مواصفات؟
أتوقع في المستقبل بلا شك
لكن أنا أعتقد السؤال أو التحدي الكبير اليوم هو
كيف بتم استخدام هذه النظارة؟
أعتقد أول مليون، أول 10 مليون مستخدم
فعلًا بدفون الشركة بالاتجاه اللي لازم تركِّز عليه
لأنه اليوم غير واضح
هل يمكن استخدامها كوسيلة للتواصل
من خلال مكالمات الفديو بطريقة أجمل وألطف؟
أم نستخدمها كبديل للكمبيوتر؟
أم نستخدمها كشاشة عرض سينمائي
وتكون أجمل تجربة سينمائية نمر فيها
خصوصًا لو دخلنا عالم ثلاثي الأبعاد؟
الكثير من الأسئلة اللي إذا المستخدم بدأ يعطيني بيانات
ويقول لي أنا استخدم هذا الجهاز في هذا الاتجاه
ببدأ أوجّه التقنية في هذا الاتجاه
وأتخلَّص من المزايا اللي أنا حطيتها
لكن بلا شك كان فيه فرد عضلات غير طبيعي
كمية التقنيات المطروحة
لدرجة أنه يقول لك فيه 500 شهادة اختراع
تم رفعها مع النظارة هذه أو من خلال النظارة هذه
أتوقع قد تكلمنا يمكن أنا وإياك
على وحدة منهم حق التحكم باليد وكذا
بس معاذ نقطة الأخذ أو قراءة المعطيات من أول المستخدمين
ذكرتني بعد سنة من إطلاق الآيباد
لو تتذكر في أحد مؤتمرات أبل
كان فيه فيديو على
كيف استخدموا الناس الآيباد السنة الماضية
وكان يوضِّح أنه فيه استخدامات تعليمية
فيه استخدامات الذكريات
فيه استخدامات الرسم
وفعلًا مشوا من هناك وكملوا البناء
أتفق معك أول سنة بيكون فيه قراءة قريبة
أول آيفون عبدالله ما كان فيه كاميرا
اللي هو آيفون تو جي
ما كان فيه كاميرا
ولا كان فيه تطبيقات خارجية
كان بس تطبيقات أبل
استخدام الناس لها هو اللي يبيّن مدى احتياج الناس أنه يكون فيه كاميرا
مع أن قبل حتى ما ينزل آيفون كثير من جوالات نوكيا وغيرها
كانت الكاميرا خاصية رئيسية فيها
لكن أيضًا أبل كانت حريصة على تطوير كاميرتها الخاصة
فهذا كان يأخذ وقت معهم إلى أخره
فأعتقد المستخدم سيقود أبل إلى المكان الصحيح
لكن هنا يجي سؤال واللي هو
ودي صراحة اسمع رأيك
هل هذه النظارة أكثر شيء يقال عن أبل
منذ وفاة ستيف جوبز أو تركه للشركة عام 2010
وتوفي عام 2011
أنه لن تستطيع هذه الشركة أن تأتي بمنتج جديد
على طراز الآيفون والآيباد واللي فعلًا كانوا ثوريين
من ناحية تغيير استخدامات الناس حول العالم
وتغيير تجربة المستخدم اتجاه مثلًا شيء مثل الجوال
والأهم من هذا ثوريين على مستوى الشركة نفسها
إلى اليوم اثنان وخمسون بالمئة من مبيعات الشركة العام الماضي أتت من الآيفون
ولو حطينا الآيفون والآيباد مع بعض
يمكن نوصل إلى سبعون بالمئة من إيرادات كل الشركة
مع أنه الشركة أصلًا هي شركة كمبيوترات
فالسؤال هو
هل الشركة قادرة على أنها تصنع آيفون جديد أو آيباد جديد
بقدراتها الحالية؟
بعد غياب المؤسس صاحب الرؤية النافذة
ولّا أيش رأيك؟ كيف تشوف أنت جواب هذا السؤال بعد شوفة النظارة اليوم؟
طبعًا هذا يؤرِّق تنفيذيين أبل في أكثر من مرة خلال السنوات الماضية
مع مثلًا الماك برو الكبير حق المصممين
يقولون الأشياء اللي ابتكروها
وبعدين يقولون كلمة ابتكار يذكرونها أكثر من مرة
على أساس يحاولون يسوون مساواة
أو موازنة بين وجهة نظرهم ووجهة نظر الناس
أنا أعتقد فيجن برو كان أحد أهم العلامات لعشرة أو اثنا عشر سنة الماضية
أنه نقدر نتخيل شيء من الصفر جديد ومختلف تمامًا
أعتقد التحدي بالنسبة لهم معاذ، أنه نقطة إنطلاق فيجن برو
في مساحة الاستهلاك أو المستخدمين
أبدر بكثير من نقطة إنطلاق الآيفون في الجوالات
فالجوالات خاصةً، حتى الشبه ذكية
صار لها كم سنة وكان واضح إن هذا هو التوجُّه القادم
كان فيه نقاشات كثيرة على قلم، بدون قلم
أيش نموذج التشغيل وكذا
وجاء الآيفون حسم التوجه هذا بشكل كبير
لكن فيجن برو أو كاستخدامات الذكاء، الواقع المختلط بين الافتراضي والمعزز
نقطة الإنطلاق شوي أبدر
لما نقارنها في هذاك الجانب
ما أعتقد أنهم جاوبوا بـ نعم قوية
لكن إذا أخذت فرضية أنه هذا التوجُّه أعتقد أنه حتى مقارنة بـ الكويست
مقارنة بالأجهزة الأخرى الجهاز أقوى تقنيًا بكثير
كثير من المواصفات حتى الصغيرة
العمل عليها والتأكد أنها تشتغل بشكل واضح كبيرة جدًا
ترى حتى ما تكلمنا عنها معاذ
بس فكرة استخدام شريحة إم تو وشريحة جديدة آر ون
تكلمنا عن إنفيديا، قبل حلقة أو حلقتين
مو هيّن أنك تروح تصمم شريحة عشان تخدم نوع واحد من العمل
وغالبًا لو صممتها صح بكون الأداء خرافي
مو بس أنها تأخذ هامش ربح أكبر
فأعتقد إجابة قوية للسؤال
هل هي إجابة للسؤال اللي يبغونه، أو لا يزال بدري؟
ما ندري أيش الاستخدام القادم لهذه التقنية
صراحة أنت قلت شيء ذكرني فعلًا بأول ما شفت النظارة
تذكرت كيف أنه كل الأجهزة الشبه ذكية وقت نزول الآيفون
كان عندها القلم أو لوحة المفاتيح أو الاثنين مع بعض
وكيف أنه ستيف جوبز كان جدًا واضح وصريح وحاسم وحازم في هذا الموضوع
أنه لن يكون هناك قلم ولن يكون هناك لوحة مفاتيح
وهذا الشيء خلاص لا نقاش فيه
وفاز في المعركة بشكل واضح
فأيضًا جاءت اليوم أبل وأعطت تصريح خطير
وقالت لن يكون هناك أداة تحكُّم بالنظارات
لأنه كل النظارات اليوم موجودة وأكيد شفتوها في أماكن كثيرة
تلبسها وأنت ماسك شيئين في يدك، أدوات التحكُّم
هذه اللي تعطي إشارات للنظارة
فـ أبل جاءت وقالت أيش هذه الفوضى، وبصراحة منطقي
إذا قدرت تبني تقنية تعمل نفس عمل أدوات التحكم
شكرًا شكرًا ما كان يحتاج هذا
حسيت أنه كان فيه تصريح خطير هنا، أو كان فيه نوع من الهيمنة التقنية
أي نعم أخذوا وقت أطول وهذه عادتهم، لكن أتوا بمنتج متفوق تقنيًا
طبعًا أنا عندي نقطة هنا على موضوع هل هذا الأيفون جديد أو لا؟
أعتقد الآيباد نزل عام 2010 أو 2009
والآيفون 2007 أو 2011
الآيفون 2007 تقريبًا
من 2010 و2011 بعد ما نزل الآيباد ترى ما نزلوا منتجات حقيقية جديدة
الساعة نزلت عام 2015
عاد، هل نعتبر الساعة منتج ثوري أم لا؟
نقدر نقول إنها غيَّرت عالم الساعات بشكل كبير
وصار الآن سؤال طبيعي أيش الساعة الذكية اللي تلبسها؟
فممكن نقول أنه الساعة غيَّرت تعريف الساعات
ما أختلف معك بس الساعة كانت جزء في التقنية الملبوسة
بس حجم السؤال نفسه وأهميته للمستهلك النهائي ليس بحجم الجوانب السابقة
طبعًا
فمهما سوَّت الساعة أنت الأرقام اللي ذكرتها على سوق الساعات ترى مو هيِّن
يعني 30% تقريبًا من عدد الساعات، بس 60% من الإيرادات
معدل كقيمة للساعة الواحدة أعلى بكثير
ولسه ماسك لحالك جزء كبير من السوق
بس لو أبل بكرة قالت ببطِّل ساعات أبل
لا، أتفق معك
وأيضًا «الإيربودز» نزلت عام 2016
عندنا فجوة ما بين الآيباد إلى الساعة 2015
بعدين السنة اللي بعدها «الإيربودز»
طبعًا هل «الإيربودز» منتج ثوري؟
ما أدري صراحة، لكن وما أتوقع
وبعدين من 2016 إلى اليوم 2023 ترى ما في أي منتج حقيقي
فيه نعم تحولوا إلى
تطويرات
تطويرات في المنتجات حقتهم
المعالجات معالجات أو السيلكون حقهم حق أبل
المعالجات الخاصة فيهم الانتقال من معالجات أبل
كان فيه تطورات تقنية حقيقية
لكنها في النهاية ما أثَّرت على تجربة المستخدم بشكل استثنائي
فهل تكون هي
معاذ، سوق الأسهم يقول لا على فكرة
وقت الإعلان لما بدؤوا يتكلمون أكثر على جانب الأعمال
سعر السهم نزل شوي
ثم بدأ يصحح
بعدين لما أعلنوا على السعر بالخط الكبير نزل مرة ثانية
فسوق الأسهم، المستثمرين يقولون لا زلنا ما ندري ما نتوقع
بس مثل ما قلت «فيجن برو» هل يكون فيه نسخة أقل؟
هل لما الناس تبدأ تستخدمها فعلًا بتشوف فرق شاسع؟
أنه اسمع يسوى؟
أعتقد عندهم أيضًا ترى ميزة تنافسية خرافية
أنه لو فعلًا كل مستنداتك وكل استخداماتك وكل هذه الأشياء ترتبط بشكل سلس جدًا
زي لما تغيِّر أيفونك لأيفون جديد على طول بدون ما تفقد شيء
ترى هذه لحالها حاجز كبير تنزله
تقول على طول أبدأ وكمّل وين ما كنت
أنا طبعًا أرجع وأقول أو أتساءل
هل بالمستقبل إننا بنلبس نظارات بهذا الحجم على وجوهنا؟
أنا شخصيًا ما أعتقد
نعم بتكون موجودة ونعم لها استخدامات
مثل نظارات مِتا باعت تقريبًا 10 مليون قطعة إلى اليوم
بتكون موجودة ويكون لها استخدامات معينة
لكني أعتقد هذا هو المستقبل مثل ماهو اليوم مستقبلنا أو حاضرنا
اللي هو الجوالات والرقاب المنحنية للأسفل
هل بكون المستقبل تدخل أي مكان عام أو خاص
تلقى الناس كلها جالسة ولابسة نظارات؟
أنا أستبعد الشيء هذا
وصراحةً شفت رسم لفنان برازيلي
كان يتكلم عن كيف أنه المستقبل بكون كل أحد على وجهه خطوط واضحة
بسبب النظارات اللي لابسها على الوجه
كبار وصغار وأطفال وغيرهم
فحسيت أنه هذا كان يجيب عن التساؤل
أكيد النظارة ما بتترك خطوط، مع أنه ما استبعد على الاستخدام طويل
لكن أنا أستبعد صراحة أنه يكون
حتى قريب من أثر الآيفون، لكن قد يكون بوابة لاستخدامات مستقبلية
لا زلنا لا نعلم عنها
أرجِّح أنا سالفة الشاشات
قد تكون بديل لشاشات التلفزيون وشاشات العرض أو غيرها
بحكم أنها بتكون تجربة أفضل بكثير من أي شاشة ممكن أن ننتجها
خاصةً، أنه فيها شاشتين وكل واحدة بتكون (4K)
فبالتالي الجودة بتكون عالية جدًا
في نقطة معاذ على نقطة متابعة مكان البؤبؤ أو العين
أعتقد الإعلانات في التطبيقات اللي تستخدم إعلانات في فيجن برو
بتكون كأنه قسم جديد في الإعلانات للشركات
في التسعير للإعلانات للشركات
حتى ما يقول لك أحطها فوق أو تحت أو يسار زي المواقع
اللي غالبًا الناس تروح هنا
يقدر يبدأ يبيعك
أحط إعلانك في المكان اللي عين هذا الشخص تروح له
بيصير أعتقد نوع شوي مختلف من الإعلانات
نحمد الله أنه التقنية هذه عند أبل
اللي أصلًا ما تحب الإعلانات كثير
إيه ما بيظهرها لك في الآلة الحاسبة بس بتظهر في التطبيق الثاني اللي بتنزله
طيب، عبدالله أنا أشوف أطلنا الحديث عن النظارة
ويمكن أكثر مما توقعنا
فأحس لازم نقفل الموضوع
ونتجه إلى صراع محلي لطيف وخفيف ما بين كريم وطلبات ودليفيرو
شفت الخبر حق كريم؟
أول شيء أيش اللي صار؟
كريم أعلنت حملة
أتوقع كانت فقط في الإمارات إذا ما غلطت
كانت نرجِّع لك درهم أو ندفع لك درهم على كل دقيقة تأخير في التوصيل
بحد أقصى عشر دراهم لكل طلب
والفكرة من كلامنا السابق أنه على التطبيقات الخارقة وغيرها
يبغون يدخلون في جانب التوصيل و يكسبون بشكل كبير
جاء كثير من ردات الفعل السلبية من بعض المستخدمين وكذلك من المنافسين
أنه إذا أنت حطيت شيء زي كذا تسوِّي ضغط على عمال التوصيل
إنهم يوصلون بالوقت، وبالتالي تؤثر على سلامتهم
أنه يحاول يسرع، ولّا يحاول يأخذ أي طريق مختصر
أي شيء عشان يتفادى الغرامة هذه
وصارت سالفة بين الجميع
وكريم تقول أنا سجلي للسلامة في العمل أعلى من الباقين
الباقين يقولون لا أيش دعوة أيش تسوّي زي كذا
نحن نؤمن بالتوصيل السريع بس ما نؤمن بإيذاء الموظفين
فيه تصعيد شوي صار كمبادئ مو بس كحملة
والله يا أخي دراما حلوة أنا أتمنى نشوفها أكثر بين الشركات المتنافسة
أحسن عندنا في المنطقة فيه نوع من التحفُّظ
على المنافسة الشرسة بين الشركات الناشئة والتقنية
أنا أتذكر أول كان دائمًا فيه منافسة شرسة
بين كريم وأوبر، وما غير يدفعون بعض
إلى حدٍ بعيد فيه نوع من المناوشات العلنية وغير العلنية
اليوم مفتقدين للشيء هذا السوق
فأنا صراحة كنت سعيد لما رأيت الخبر
لأنه الرؤساء التنفيذيين حق كل من «طلبات»، وأيضًا «دليفيرو» هم اللي علَّقوا على الخبر
وهذا شي غريب أنه ليش رئيس تنفيذي يعلِّق
بس أنا استانست
مو لأني أحب المشاكل لا سمح الله، لكن شيء جميل
بعد ما طلبت مشاكل دقيقتين، تقول أنا أحب المشاكل الله يوفق الجميع
لا طبيعي نحن الشركات نتنافس فأكيد أنه أبغى أبيِّن عيوب المنافس حقي
وهذا شيء أعتقد أنه صحي
وطبيعي كل شركة تدافع عن نفسها
لكن كريم قالت نحن أصلًا الرسوم هذه ما تُخصَم من السائق
أو موصل الطلبات أو الكابتن
فبالتالي ليش أنتم زعلانين؟
إحنا اللي بندفعها من جيوبنا
وبعدين نحن مو قاعدين نوعد العميل أنه بنعطيه الطلب في وقت قياسي
نحن قاعدين نقول للعميل نحن نتوقع أنه الطلب يوصل خلال هذه المدة من الدقائق
إذا نحن فشلنا في تقدير المدة
بنعوضك درهم عن كل دقيقة والعرض له مدة صلاحية فهو عرض ذكي
أنه أبغى أسوِّي نوع من زيادة الثقة في تقديراتي الزمنية لأوقات التوصيل
أو كأني أقول الناس تراني مرة واثق لدرجة أني بدفع لكم في حال أني أنا ما أدِّيت
لكن أعجبني صراحة كيف أنه الشركات شافوها فرصة للهجوم وانتهاز الفرصة
وبعدين جت كريم وعايرتهم
هذا اللي أضحكني أنا
لو تذكر قبل سنة تقريبًا
إيه تقريبًا قبل سنة بالضبط كان في عملية إضراب من سائقي «طلبات» و«ديليفرو»
وما أدري صراحة إذا كانوا كريم معهم أو لا
بس الأكيد حق طلبات هم اللي كانوا زعلانين
مدير كريم للغذاء أو نقل الطلبات قال
أنا ما أدري كيف طلبات تتكلم عنّا، وقبل سنة هم سائقينهم مضربين عنهم
بسبب عدم رضاهم بالعمل معهم، نحن ولا السائق توقف عن العمل معنا
على قولتهم إذا بيتك من زجاج لا ترمي الناس بحجارة
وقال نحن ترى ما نجمع الطلبات بس عشان نحاول نسهِّل أو نقلل التكلفة، كل واحد لحاله
فمرة ثانية ما كان بس دفاع، كان دفاع من خلال الهجوم
بس معاذ السوق هذا مو هيِّن
قرأت تحليل على «دورداش» خلال الثلاث أو أربع سنوات الماضية في أمريكا
وكيف انتقلوا في خلال يمكن أربع سنوات إذا ماني بمخطئ
من 16% حصة سوقية في أمريكا إلى 50% تقريبًا أو أكثر بشوي
فعلًا أول شيء الوقت قصير ومنافسة شرسة
بس جاؤوا واتبعوا عدد من الاستراتيجيات
أولًا، قالوا نروح للمطاعم اللي ما عندها توصيل
ما نتنافس على نفس المطاعم
ثانيًا، قالوا خل نعطي بيانات كثيرة
للمطاعم هذه خليهم يبسطون معنا
أيش اللي مطلوب في المنطقة فيغيرون قائمة الطعام ويساعدوننا
رقم ثلاثة قالوا نروح للمحافظات مو بس المدن الكبيرة
لأنه فيه عوائل أكبر فيطلبون معدل الطلب أكبر
وكذلك دعموا بعض عمال التوصيل والمطاعم في فترة كورونا
قدموا لهم أموال في البداية بعدين ترجِّع لي إياها، زي البطاقة أو الرصيد
قصدي حساس القطاع هذا، والفائز فيه، فيه فوائد خرافية
ما أتوقع هذه آخر مناوشة نشوفها في المنطقة
لأنه لا تزال المنطقة فيها لاعبين كثير عندهم حجم جيد
وترى تجي مثلًا للسعودية فيه عندك جاهز وعندك هنقرستيشن أيضًا
لا تنسى أنه هذا يعتبر مشكلة بسيطة أو مناوشة بسيطة في رأيي
لأنه التعويض عن التأخير من زمان
محلات بيتزا في أمريكا وفي عدد من الدول تقولك لو أكثر من نصف ساعة لا تدفع
ماهو بفكرة جديدة جدًا أنه أعوضك لو تأخرت
بس أعتقد مع المنافسة بيضطرون الشركات يسوون حملات أكثر إبداعية
اللي ممكن يصير لها ردات فعل من المنافسين إذا ما يبغون يقدمون نفس العرض
أنا زي ما قلت صراحة أني سعيد، وأدعو الشركات بشكل عام إنها تتناوّش أكثر
ويصير بينهم شوية أكشن وحماس
وهذا شيء طبيعي حتى نلقاه دائمًا مثلًا ما بين بيبسي وكوكولا
مرسيدس وبي إم دبليو
وغيرها من الشركات اللي فعلًا تتنافس
للحصول على انتباه العميل، وعلى تقديم أفضل منتج وخدمة للعميل
طيب عبدالله، أنا ودي ننتقل صراحة لجولة استثنائية صارت الأسبوع الماضي في تركيا
من طراز دال بقيمة 105 مليون دولار لشركة «إنسايدر» التركية
ونحن نتكلم عن هذه الجولة لعدة أسباب
السبب الأول حجم الجولة في هذا التوقيت
السبب الثاني هو نشاط الشركة، واللي مرتبط بشكل رئيسي بالذكاء الاصطناعي
وراح نتكلم أكثر عن نشاطهم
والسبب الثالث هم المستثمرين
واللي أحد أهمهم هو صندوق قطر الاستثماري
أو جهاز قطر الاستثماري «كيو آي إيه»
وطبعًا سبحان الله قبل فترة كنت أسولف مع أحد الأصدقاء
واكتشفت أنه أيضًا حتى صندوق «ومضة كابيتال»
أحد المستثمرين في الشركة
والشركة أُسست عام 2012
باختصار تحاول أنها تقدم منصة واحدة
للشركات خصوصًا الضخمة
بحيث إنها تقدر تدير عملية تجربة المستخدم الخاصة فيهم وعملية التواصل مع العميل
بحيث أنه يكون فيه عنده زي الملف الشخصي واحد عند الشركة على المنصة
ومن خلاله تقدر تتواصل معه بالبريد الإلكرتوني وبالرسائل النصية وبالواتساب
والأهم من هذا كله أنها تبني له ملف شخصي
ويستخدم الذكاء الصناعي مع الوقت بحيث أنه يبدأ يعرف أيش الأشياء اللي يحبها
وأيش الأشياء اللي ما يحبها
فيقدم له عروض أو يقدم له منتجات
عنده ثقة عالية أنه بشتريها
فالوعد الرئيسي إني أنا غير إني بنظِّم لك عملية التواصل مع العميل في مكان واحد
إني أنا بقدر أفهم عميلك
وأعطيه منتجات بيشتريها
فبالتالي أزيد قيمة صرف العميل الواحد معك
ونسبة الولاء وإلى آخره
فمنتج يخدم مبيعات الشركات لدرجة أنه عندهم 1200 شركة من كبار الشركات حول العالم
مثل برقر كينق، والطيران السنغافوري
والعديد من الشركات الضخمة جدًا
نتكلم عن الشركات العملاقة
فعلًا أنه منتج يستخدم أو يستهدف الشركات الضخمة جدًا
معاذ، أعتقد نقطة تجربة العميل مثل ما قلت أنت
الجزء الأول منها هي تنظيم العملية
المستوى الثاني والثالث منها هي إضافة نقاط أخذ، يعني تقييم نوعية الخدمة
عشان تقدر فعلًا تبني هذا الملف الُمفصَّل عن الشخص
على سبيل المثال، الخطوط السنغافورية أنت ذكرتها كمثال
أعتقد مع الوقت إذا فعلًا النظام جيد
ممكن تأخذ من العميل حتى تربط إذا يقيِّم الرحلة، آخر الرحلة
أيش اللي عجبك أيش اللي ما عجبك
ويرتبط بالملف، بعدين تقدر مثلًا تعطيه عرض ثاني لو ما كان راضي
وممكن حتى تضيف نقاط المراجعة وأخذ النقاط هذه
«تويوتا» وشركات السيارات اللي عملائهم ممكن كذلك تأخذ
مع الوقت مع ارتباط السيارات بالشبكة
ممكن تأخذ منهم فعلًا حتى المعلومات حق الاستخدام
السرعة، أماكن الاستخدام، طريقة التنقل
وتعطيهم عروض، أو توقعات أفضل للصيانة
والتكاليف أيش اللي يستهلك
فأعتقد هي شركة متموضعة في مكان
اللي هي تحسين تجربة العميل
في وقت هي جانب منافسة كبير
أول كان بس توفير نوع خدمة جديد، أو توفير منتج جديد
الآن تجربة العميل لحالها ممكن تخليك تختار الشركة ألف أو الشركة باء
وعلى طاري السيارات يمكن نقاش الناس الكثير لما واحد يجي يشتري سيارة
مو أيش نوع السيارة أيش فيها
الوكالة
أيش وضع الوكالة والصيانة اللي فيها؟
تخيل هذه ضرب مئة أو ضرب ألف
أنه الشركة ولّا الوكالة يكون عندها معلومات أفضل بكثير
وتقييم الشركة مليارين الآن دولار مع هذه الجولة
ليست هيِّنة بكل تأكيد
هي قاربت المليارين، ما وصلت للمليارين لكنها قريبة
ما أفصحوا بالضبط كم الرقم
وسبب زيادة التقييم أنه الشركة قاعدة تنمو بالإيرادات
على سبيل المثال نمت 282% في شمال أميركا فقط
يعني 3.8 أضعاف
وهذا رقم ماهو بسهل، طبعًا ما ندري عن حجم عملياتهم في أمريكا
لكن هذا يُظهر حجم الاهتمام اللي كلنا عارفين عنه في مجال الذكاء الصناعي
وأيضًا فيه شركات الساس لأنها إذا نجحت يكون نجاحها مبهر
واقتصاديات الوحدة عندها ممتازة
طبعًا الشركة عندها نية أنها تطرح في الأسواق العامة عام 2025 أو 2026
لكن هنا عبدالله أبغى نأخذ كذا مخرج بسيط ونتكلم عن الاستثمارات الجريئة في المنطقة
بغض النظر سواءً تركيا معانا في المنطقة أو لا
لكنها أيضًا تعاني مثل ما عانينا مسبقًا
نحن شفنا في الربع الأول من العام
انخفضت الاستثمارات عندنا في المنطقة قرابة الـ 50% إذا ما أنا بغلطان
فأشوف أنا أيش صار في تركيا؟
في تركيا الربع الأول كان هو أسوأ ربع منذ عشرة أرباع
انخفضت الاستثمارات من 1.2 مليار العام الماضي، اللي هو 2022
إلى 56 مليون دولار في الربع هذا من هذا العام
أتكلم عن انخفاض مخيف جدًا من ناحية النسبة
فطبعًا وجود شركات مثل هذه
مثل «إنسايدر» شركات ناجحة
بلا شك أنها تعزز دور المنظومة
نتكلم على حجم الجولة هذه يساوي ضعفي الاستثمارات اللي تمت في الربع كامل الربع الأول
فعشان كذا وجود شركات استثنائية
تساعد المنظومة بشكل عام
وهذا اللي صار عندنا أيضًا في المنظومة
شركات مثل «فلاورد» وشركات مثل «نعناع»
جمعوا جولات استثنائية
ولولاها كانت الأرقام بتكون أقل بكثير
عاد ما ندري أيش الوضع في الربع الثاني
لكن ننتظر النتائج
وهذه الشركات الاستثنائية في جولات جيم ودال وما بعدها
لها أثر مضاعف لأنها تذكِّر المستثمرين أنه استثمارك في هذا المجال
إذا كانت شركة ناجحة
لها تخارج جيد لك كمستثمر
فمو بس أثرها المباشر لكن لها مضاعف جيد جدًا
طيب عبدالله أنا ودي صراحة ننتقل من الشركة التركية «إنسايدر»
اللي معتمدة على الذكاء الاصطناعي في تطبيقاتها
لمقال مهم لمارك أندريسن مؤسس صندوق أندريسن هورويتز
واللي كتب مقال عن الذكاء الاصطناعي الأسبوع الماضي
واللي يحاول من خلاله أن يجيب عن الكثير من التساؤلات والمخاوف حول الذكاء الاصطناعي
أنا أدري أنك قرأت المقال، وعندك رأي واضح ومتحمس تجاهه
فودِّي اسمع منك صراحةً
كيف شفت المقال حق مارك؟
مقال مارك فيه فكرتين أو ثلاث رئيسية
الفكرة الأولى أن كل التطورات اللي صارت في البشرية
دافعها الرئيسي الذكاء البشري
والذكاء الاصطناعي يدعم ويسرِّع هذا الذكاء البشري
كمبدأ المفروض أنه يحسِّن الحياة البشرية
ويقول أنه الناس اللي يقولون فيه مخاطر
خلينا نأخذ المخاطر، هذه واحدة واحدة
قتل البشرية كلها
أو قتل الوظائف، أوا قيم المجتمع أو غيرها
ويفنِّدها واحدة واحدة من وجهة نظره
ما عدا اثنين
أولًا أنه يساعد المجرمين في تنفيذ العمليات الإجرامية بشكل أفضل، وعنده رد أو حل لها
والجانب الثاني كان جانب أمريكي أكثر
يقول، ترى الصين تسوي اللي تسويه في الذكاء الاصطناعي
إذا ما ردينا، أيش وضعنا أمام الصين؟
ويطرح حلول
بس الفكرة الرئيسية من الحلول خلِّي الجميع ينطلق
شركات كبيرة وريادية
وبعدين بتتحسن المنتجات اللي تُقدَّم للأفراد
اللي بيقرأ المقال بالتفصيل
بنحط الرابط المقال
لكن أتمنى أني اختصرت الأفكار الرئيسية
أنا وجهة نظري، على الرغم من أنه كان فيه نقاط كثيرة مهمة
إيجابية للذكاء الاصطناعي
لكن كان فيها زاويتين
زاوية البشرية كلها
وأيضًا زاوية التحدي الأمريكي والصيني
يمكن تكلم على انقسام سكويا بعد شوي كذلك مرتبط بهذه النقطة
الجانب الثاني فيه نقاط فعلًا ما أجابها بشكل كامل
حسيت الحلول فعليًا مو بخلي الجميع ينطلق
الحلول فعليًا لا تعطي بعض الشركات امتيازات حقيقية
هو يتكلم كثير عن التحيُّز بس هو أيضًا مُتحيِّز
هو يبغى شركات ريادية في الذكاء الاصطناعي عشان صندوقه يقدر يستثمر فيها
فحسيت يحاول يقول كثير من التحيُّز في اللي خائفين
بس ما وضَّح التحيُّز المباشر له وللصندوق
على طاري التحيز فعلًا هذا اللي يوم قرأت المقال
طرأ على بالي شيئين
الشيء الأول أنه أحد أهم المستفيدين من ثورة الذكاء الاصطناعي على الصعيد المادي
بحكم أنه راح يكون عنده وصول للكثير من هذه الشركات
وبيقدر يستثمر فيها ويطلع منها
يعني فيس بوك القادمة وقوقل القادمة اللي راح تجيب ألاف المضاعفات لهم في استثماراتهم
حسيت من الطبيعي أنه يبغى يدعم هذه التقنية
بغض النظر عن مساوئها
والشيء الثاني حسيت أنه فيه أيضًا مساحة للتحيُّز الجغرافي أو المناطقي
اليوم نحن نشوف الأمريكان محتدين جدًا مع الصينيين
خصوصًا في سالفة الذكاء الاصطناعي، وشفنا الكثير من التشريعات اللي طلَّعها البيت الأبيض
ضد حتى الأمريكان إنهم يعملون في شركات تستخدم ذكاء اصطناعي صينية
أو حتى يساعدونهم في أية أبحاث
وحتى عُرِّضوا لسحب جنسياتهم وإلى آخره
فواضح أنه الأمريكان معلنين حرب بشكل شبه رسمي تجاه الصين
وكان فيه حتى عبارة واضحة وصريحة في المقال
يقون لازم نحن يا الأمريكان أو الغرب، نتفوّق في هذه الحرب
وإذا لم نتفوق فيها فهم سيتفوقون فيها
وهو يقصد الصينيين
فعبارات «نحن» و«هم» هذه ما أدري إلى أي مدى هي صحية
وقاعدين نشوفها للأسف عند الكثير من المؤثرين في عالم التقنية الأمريكية
من أهمهم طبعًا بيتر ثيل اللي أسس شركة «بالانتير»
واللي كان يقول أني أنا مع أمريكا، وأنا بدعم الجيش الأمريكي
وأنا يهمني فوز أمريكا في كل المعارك وفي الساحات
وتبقى هيمنة أمريكا وهيمنة الدولار على العالم
كان يقولها بشكل واضح وصريح
وهو أيضًا من أحد أهم المستثمرين من خلال صندوقه «فاوند جست ون»
فعلى طاري بس التحيُّز كان فيه مساحتين واضحة للتحيُّز عند مارك
تحيز لأنه هو أمريكي وعايش في أمريكا
وتحيُّز لأنه مستثمر، ومن أفضل المستثمرين
فعنده فرصة حقيقية للاستفادة من هذه الشركات
في نقطة ثانية أنا شفتها
نصف إجابة الصراحة كانت على نقطة الوظائف
يقول أنه كان فيه نفس التخوُّف في الأتمتة في الأجهزة وكذا
يقول بس بدايات 2010
بس يقول لما جات 2019 قبل كورونا كانت أعلى عدد من الوظائف
بأعلى معدل أجور
فيقول لو الذكاء الاصطناعي فعلًا سوَّى أو قدر يساهم في الخدمات أو الأعمال
يقول فيه مغالطة أنه فيه عدد من الوظائف بسوّونه المكينة أو البشر
يقول عدد الوظائف يزيد
لكن بافتراض أنه الذكاء الاصطناعي سوّى كل الوظائف في العالم
يقول تخيل التحسُّن في جودة الحياة وكذا
بس كأنه شوي راح من السؤال الحقيقي نفسه، اللي هو طيب البشر أيش بيسوّون؟
ذكرت نقاشاتنا سابقًا على الدخل الموحَّد
والناس تسوّي أشياء إبداعية
وأعمال خيرية، اجتماعية
وبس حسيت ما أقول أنه جواب صح ولّا غلط
بس تفادى الإجابة على السؤال الحقيقي
وما شفت إجابة شافية في هذاك المقطع من المقال
أنا الصراحة أتفق مع مارك في مجمل الرسالة حقته
واللي هو أنه في الغالب لن يكون ذكاء اصطناعي
أثر إيجابي
لن يكون مضرًا بالبشرية أو لن ينهي البشرية، بالشكل الذي كثير من الناس يتخيلون أو يسوقون له
وأيضًا لن يقضي على الوظائف
أنا أعتقد أكثر الناس خايفين من سالفة الوظائف
أنا ما أشوف هذا الشيء أبدًا، بالعكس أنا أشوف أنه فعلًا بتزيد الوظائف
مثل ما زادت المصانع، أيش فيك كان المصنع مثلًا في 1000 شخص
تحولّوا من 1000 إلى 100 نفس القدرة الإنتاجية
لكن هل قلَّت الوظائف؟ لا طبعًا ما قلَّت
الوظائف تتغير، الوظائف تتطور، الوظائف تتمحور حول مهارات جديدة
فبالتالي أنا ما أشوف أنه فيه خوف
دام أنه فيه ناس ودها إنها تشتغل
إذا وصلنا نحن كبشرية إلى مفهوم أصلًا ما نبغى نشتغل
وليس هدف عندنا مفهوم العمل
وقتها ممكن تكون مفاهيم مثل الدخل الموحَّد وغيرها
حلول حقيقية لحصول الفرد على القوت اليومي أو المبالغ اللازمة للمعيشة اليومية
بس غير كذا، سالفة أنه الذكاء اصطناعي بيأخذ وظيفتي
ممكن يأخذ وظيفة بعض الناس
لكن لن يكون هناك يعني وظائف أقل بشكل عام
لأنه الوظائف راح تأخذ مجرى جديد
ولا ننسى أنه أي عملية أتمتة فيها عملية توفير للتكاليف
فبالتالي فيها عملية تقليل لتكلفة الخدمة
فبالتالي عدد أكبر بستفيد من الخدمة، فبالتالي جودة حياة أفضل
وبالتالي دخل أو المحافظة على..
ارتفاع قدرة الصرف
قدرة صرف تعلى، فأنا لما يصير عندي دخل إضافي أو مصروف إضافي
أقدر أوديه لمنتج جديد
ما كنت أقدر أصلًا أشتريه قبل لأنه ما كان عندي فلوس كفاية
ما أدري ليش الصراحة فيه مبالغة شوي في طرح هذا
لكن شكرًا مارك المتحيِّز على طرحك
معاذ، واحد من الأشياء الجميلة في المقال الصراحة
كان فيها كثير من الروابط لمواضيع أو أفكار معينة
واحد منها كان زي أرشيف المتشائمين
وتروح للموقع يورِّيك التخوُّف من كل تقنية كبيرة سابقة أو أكثر التقنيات الكبيرة السابقة
صور الجرائد، تعليقات الناس
فهذا كان أيضًا رابط اتبعته من المقالة، وكان للموقع نفسه
صراحة حلو الواحد يشوف كيف الناس نظرت للتقنيات اليوم اللي نعرفها
وكثير من الناس يستخدمونها
طيب عبدالله من تخوُّف مارك
من تطوير الصينيين لقدرات الذكاء الاصطناعي اللي بتقتل البشرية
لانقسام خطير في صفوف سكويا
طبعًا فقط للتوضيح، سكويا واحد من أقدم الصناديق في العالم
أُسس في بداية السبعينات
واستثمر في أهم عمالقة التقنية
في وادي السيليكون
ويعتبر من أهم العلامات الفارقة في الاستثمار الجريء حول العالم
توسعوا مع الوقت من أمريكا إلى أوربا تحت نفس المسمى، اللي هو سكويا
وبعدين انطلقوا إلى الصين والهند
تحت مسمى سكويا الصين وسكويا الهند وشرق آسيا
لكن اليوم نسمع
أو فيه رسالة وجهوها للمستثمرين، قالوا لهم
ترى إحنا قاعدين نواجه تحديات من خلال هذا النوع من الربط بين الصناديق
نحن نتشارك العمليات الداخلية
من مثلًا عمليات التدقيق المالي والإدارة
وإدارة شؤون الموظفين وغيرها من العمليات المشتركة
نتشاركها بين الصناديق، لكن قرارات الاستثمار منفصلة تمامًا عن بعض
هذا الشيء يسبب لنا الكثير من الحساسيات بين المؤسسين
مثلًا إذا استثمر صندوق الصين في شركة فالمؤسسين في أمريكا
اللي استثمر فيهم الصندوق الأميركي يتحسسون
يقولك هذا الصندوق ينافسني من خلال الاستثمار في منافسي في الصين أو في الهند
إلى آخره من التحديات اللي هم ذكروها
فأعلنوا إعلان كان غريب الصراحة
بيفصلون الصين في صندوق منفصل ماله أي علاقة بـ سكويا
وأيضًا بيفصلون الهند في صندوق منفصل ما له أي علاقة بـ سكويا
ولن يكون حتى في الاسم كلمة سكويا
الصندوق الهندي اسمه «بيك 15»
القمة الخامسة عشر كنايةً عن
هو الاسم القديم والأول لقمة إيفرست
صحيح
وعندنا اللي هو الاسم الصيني صراحة ما يحضرني
ما أدري إذا تذكره عبدالله؟
لا والله، بس شيء مو بعيد عن سكويا
كانت لفتة جميلة لكن اسم مختلف
بينما يعني بقت أمريكا وأوربا في كفة واحدة
وهذا يذكرني حتى في رسالة مارك أنه كان يقول
أمريكا والغرب
واضح أنه فيه نوع من ما ودِّي أقول عنصرية، بس ودِّي أقول عنصرية
سبحان الله المؤسس الأوربي ما يتحسس إذا استثمرت في شركة أمريكية منافسة
لكن إذا استثمر في شركة هندية أو صينية يتحسس!
وهذا صراحة أكبر دلالة برأيي
أنه كلامهم كذب في كذب، بمعنى هم مشكلتهم الرئيسية هي التحديات
السياسية والجيوسياسية صراحةً
اللي يصير بين الصين وأمريكا
أنا أتفق معك معاذ أعتقد جزء كبير منها جيوسياسي
جيوسياسي بين أمريكا والصين بعد بالتحديد
وتكلمت عن شركات الذكاء الاصطناعي بس أعتقد حتى التحديات الأخرى اللي متوقعينها مستقبلًا
فيه سؤال هل وقعت الهند ضحية بين الاثنين؟
لأنه المنظومة الهندية تنمو
وكان فيه اثنين أو ثلاثة، من أكبر عشر صناديق الاستثمار الجريء
موجودة في الهند أصلًا، منهم سكويا
الآن قالوا خلاص ما نبغى
بس هل هي فعلًا عشان التقسيمة تتم؟
أو هل هم شافوا المنظومة الهندية كوَّنت شركات كبيرة ومليارية
بالشكل الكافي خلال العشر أو الخمسة عشر سنة الماضية
فقالوا اسمع خلاص خلينا نطلع من السوق
لا، ما أعتقد أنا السبب
أنا تحليلي السطحي يقول أنه هم شافوا
أنه لو بس فصلنا الصين بيطلع شكلنا مرة بايخ
فخلينا نفصل الهند
باختصار ترى هذه المحادثة اللي صارت في غرفة مجلس الإدارة
رحت تعيشت معهم بعد اليوم الثاني؟
بعد ما طلعت من عند مارك وتيم
رحت لهم!
معاذ أيضًا، فيه فكرة نقطتين: النقطة الأولى، أيش يعني لنا كمنطقة؟
لأنه صندوق سكويا الهند استثمر في كثير من شركات المنطقة
في أربع شركات
فالنقطة اللي ذكروها أنه القرار الاستثماري كان غير مركزي من الأساس
مهمة أعتقد في زيادة الثقة في الشركات الثانية في الصين وفي الهند
لأنه أنت في الأخير رأس مال جريء
استثمارات رأس مال جريء يعتمد على قدرة الشخص
أو الفريق في الاستثمار أنه يقدِّر أو يشوف أنه الشركة هذه مناسبة أو لها فرصة نمو كبيرة ولّا لا
وكذلك العلاقة بعد الاستثمار، الدعم، التوجيه اللي موجود، والاستمرارية معاه
فالنقطة أنه ما كانوا مرتبطين في الجانب الاستثماري
أعتقد تقلل الأثر لهذا الانفصال
وطبعًا بتزيد التكاليف اللي متحمّلة على كل من الثلاث شركات لأنه كانوا يتشاركون بعض الجوانب
وخصوصًا أعتقد على الجانب الصيني والهندي
بحكم الحجم
بس فيه هنا نقطتين، أعتقد ممكن الجانب الصيني والهندي عبدالله ممكن تقل التكاليف
لأنهم كانوا يدفعون في الغالب تكاليف لموظفين في وادي السيليكون للعمليات المشتركة
أعتقد بيوظفون ناس بشكل أرخص في دولهم
لكن أعتقد فيه أثرين هنا، أو في جهتين راح تتأثر بشكل واضح
الجهة الأولى المؤسسين، يعني أنا كمؤسس، أنا يوم جيتك جايك على أساس إنك سكويا
اليوم أنت فجأة قررت أنك لست سكويا!
زي كأنك أنت جاي تستثمر فيني، وأنا قررت بعدين أكون شي ثاني
فهذا تحدي، أتذكَّر أحد المؤسسين اللي استثمرت معاه سكويا في المنطقة كنت أسولف معاه
كان يقول لي أنا كان حلم حياتي استثمار سكويا معي
هل هذا اندثار حلم هذا الشخص أم لا؟
هذا علامة استفهام
الشيء الثاني والأهم عبدالله
وهنا نقطة مهمة أيضًا عن سكويا بحكم من عراقة الاسم هذا
سكويا تأخذ أكثر من الصناديق الأخرى كرسوم إدارية وكنسبة ربح من الصندوق
المعتاد في عالم صناديق الاستثمار الجريء إنها تأخذ 2% سنويًا كرسوم إدارية
وعشرون بالمئة نسبة استقطاع من الأرباح، أرباح الصندوق
لكن سكويا تأخذ 2.75 سنويًا
وثلاثون بالمئة من الربح
وطبعًا هذا الشيء هم يأخذونه لأنهم سكويا اسم عريق
لا الفرضية
بس معاذ هي دائرة مغلقة
أنه اسمي عريق وعندي نجاحات كثيرة، يعني أكثر المؤسسين الجيدين زي المثال اللي ذكرته
بجون عندي
بجون عندي أول
فبدخل أول، فعوائدك بتكون أعلى من غيرك
فاستحق نسبة ربح أكثر
الآن هذه الفرضية مختلفة تمامًا في الصين والهند
فأنا كمستثمر استثمر في الصندوق الهندي مثلًا
هل يتم مراجعة الاتفاقية اللي تمَّت؟
لأني أنا استثمرت على فرضية معينة
أهم ركائزها أنك أنت سكويا
اليوم أنت ما أنت سكويا
أنت جهة انفصلت عن سكويا وما عندك حقوق الاسم
نعم، يمكن الناس تعرف أنك أنت سابقًا سكويا
الفريق لسا جيِّد
بس بعد خمس سنوات أو بعد ثلاث سنوات ما أنت سكويا
لأنه ذاكرة الناس ذاكرة ضحلة جدًا
ما بتتذكر
خصوصًا الجيل الجديد من رواد الأعمال اللي يدخل السوق كل كم سنة
ما عنده ذاكرة مفصَّلة عن أيش صار في الماضي
فما أعرف صراحة، أحس أنه هذه أسئلة مبهمة
أعتقد لو أنا كنت شريك في صندوق، بمعنى أني أحد المستثمرين في الصندوق
فأبغى توضيح واضح حول معنى هذا الشيء، وأثره على رسوم الصندوق
لكن يعني غريب صراحة فعلًا كيف آثار السياسة
كيف اليوم تتوغل في التقنية
ونشوفها على مستوى مارك
ونشوفها على مستوى بيتر ثيير
والآن على مستوى أحد أعرق الصناديق سكويا
وما ندري أيش يعني المنطقة
لأنه كثير من الصناديق هذه الضخمة المعروفة
تستثمر صح في المراحل الأولى، لكن كذلك عندها قدرة أنها تكتب الشيكات الكبيرة
بمراحل جيم ودال وهاء ولّا غيرها
ونحن في منطقة الشرق الأوسط مقبلين
فيه نوع عدد كبير من الشركات جمعت جولات ألف
أو حتى باء بدأنا نشوف بنجاحات جيدة
وتقدُّم ملحوظ في نموذج الأعمال
فهل بنشوف التأخُّر في بعض هذه الصناديق اللي يشوفون أيش يسوون؟
فبالتالي لازم نعتمد على لاعبين محليين
يا موجودين أو بيجون في الفترة القادمة؟
ولّا الشركات العائلية، ولّا الشركات الكبرى استحواذات
أعتقد يغيّر شوي من خارطة الطريق
للشركات الريادية اللي ماشية أو لا زالت تستمر
لأنه أيضًا تعريفنا كمنطقة مو واضح بالنسبة لبعض هذه الصناديق الدولية
لسنا في غرب أوربا بكل تأكيد
بعيدين
بس أيضًا
لسنا في شرق آسيا
ما نحن بشرق آسيا، لكن سكويا كان المسمى والتركيز الأساسي هناك
فجاوا واستثمروا هنا بحكم أنهم الأقرب
فحتى ترسيم الحدود بينهم
سكويا ولّا غيرهم ولّا الشركات الأخرى
أيش بيكون؟
بعد خمس سنين سكويا الأمريكية
شافت فرصة ممتازة في تايلاند ولّا في كوريا ولّا شيء
هل بينهم اتفاقية أنه ما أجي؟
ولّا ما بينهم اتفاقية وأقدر أجي؟
لكنها مو استراتجيته الرئيسية
أعتقد جزء من التعقيدات بينحل السنة هذه
قالوا نهاية السنة بيفصلون الخدمات والتدقيق واللي ذكرتها
لكن أعتقد فيه تعقيدات بتجي الفترة القادمة
بكرة يجي حق الصيني يقول خلال أنا شركة لحالي بتوسَّع، أنا شايف فرصة بالهند
ويجي حق الهند يقول أنا بتوسَّع في مدري وين، ولّا أبغى أستثمر في شركة أمريكية
ومافي طريقة حقيقية لحوكمة هذا الجزء
هذا الجانب، إذا فعلًا أنت فصلت الشركات عن بعض
التحدي الحقيقي اللي أيضًا بيصير معاذ
جمع الأموال للصناديق الجديدة للشركة الصينية والشركة الهندية
أو الصندوق الصيني والصندوق الهندي
لأنه هل فعلًا تقدر تروح للمستثمرين وتخليهم يستثمرون معك؟
المستثمرين الأمريكيين، واضح التوجّه
أنه ما نبغى نستثمر في الصين على سبيل المثال بشكل كبير
فهل أنت بتروح للمستثمرين الصينيين الآن أو اللي في المنطقة وتحاول تقول لهم
أنا عندي فرصة بالصين ومؤمن بالصين؟
أنا ما أدري كيف تعتمد بالصين
طبعًا هذه الصناديق حققت نجاحات كبيرة في هذه الدول، في الهند
استثمروا في أهم قصص النجاح
وأيضًا في الصين
لدرجة أنه حتى الرئيس الأمريكي حق سكويا
يجلس على مجلس إدارة شركة «باي دانس» اللي تملك تيك توك
فبالتالي هذا كان أحد أهم الأسئلة: هل تنزل من مجلس الإدارة ولّا أيش بيصير بالضبط؟
من ناحية إقناع المستثمرين أنه عندهم القدرة
على الاستثمار بأفضل وأجود الشركات أعتقد تجاوزوا هذه المرحلة
لأنه أعمار الصناديق ما هي بالبسيط
لكن هل زي قلت أول هل قدرتهم كانت جات من خلال الوسم التجاري حقهم اللي يميَّزهم
واللي أي رائد أعمال حول العالم يعرفهم فيه؟
هل غياب هذا الوسم بقلل من عدد الفرص المميزة اللي ودَّه أنها تروح عندهم بشكل أولي؟
هذا السؤال اللي أعتقد جوابه راح يكون
أو بيظهر في السنوات القادمة
فيه نقطة أخيرة بس معاذ ودي أذكرها في هذا الموضوع، اللي هو قد يكون جزء من القرار
اللي هو تبسيط أحد أهم الأسئلة في اتخاذ القرار
اللي هو وين أحط الفلوس؟
أو وين أجمع الصناديق الجديدة حقتي؟
كيف أحط انكشافي على شرق آسيا، انكشافي على الصين، انكشاف على أمريكا وغرب أوربا؟
فيسِّهل هذا الموضوع بشكل كبير
لأنه يقلل أسئلة الاقتصاد الكلي أو الماكرو
بيصير خلاص أنت تركيزك في هذه المنطقة
تحاول تحصل على أفضل الفرص في هذه المنطقة
ويسهلها، يعني استراتيجياتهم تتبسّط بأحد المتغيرات
اللي هو وين كمنطقة جغرافية وين أحط المبلغ أو الفلوس؟
بس يطلِّع تحديات أخرى كذلك
خصوصًا أنه عملية اتخاذ القرار كانت من الأساس منفصلة
ما كانت كلها، لازم ترجع إلى لجنة استثمار واحدة في كاليفورنيا
عبدالله، عندك أي اقتراحات لنا هذا الأسبوع؟
عندي اقتراح ما كنت أتوقع أني أشوفه، اللي هو مارك زوكربيرغ
«رجع على بودكاست «ليكس فريدمان
لمقابلة ثانية، أنا شفت بعض المقاطع منها كتجهيز لحلقة اليوم
كويست ثري جهازهم للواقع المعزز والافتراضي
وكذلك تعليقه على «فيجن برو» منتج أبل
بس ما شفتها كلها بس فيها جوانب حلوة من ناحية الفصل
وقرارات الفصل اللي صارت السنة الماضية
كيف يشوف التوظيف والعمل عن بُعد؟
وكيف يشوف دور الذكاء الاصطناعي في «مِتا»؟
فمتحمس أكمل الباقي
وتوقعت لسا بيأخذ وقت زيادة قبل لا يرجع على لكس تريسمنت مرة ثانية
عبدالله نشوفك على خير الأسبوع القادم
يعطيك العافية معاذ
شكرًا لكم، وشكرًا لفريق السوق
في إدارة الإنتاج أصيل بافرط
وفي الإعداد أسامة المشيقح
وفي التحرير عدي عيسى
وفي الهندسة الصوتية يوسف إبراهيم
وفي التلوين عبدالمجيد العطاس
وفي التصوير عبدالرحمن عبود
هذا بودكاست السوق، أحد منتجات شركة ثمانية للنشر والتوزيع